Bienvenido al nivel 2 de ecuaciones lineales.
Así que vamos a hacer un ejemplo.
Yo tengo la siguiente ecuación, "2x" más
3 esto lo quiero hacer igual a -15.
Y bueno, ¿cómo resuelvo esta ecuación lineal?
Y la respuesta es bastante sencilla,
para resolver esta ecuación lineal, lo primero
que hay que hacer es dejar todo lo que tenga
que ver con las variables de un lado de la
ecuación y todo lo que tiene que ver con
los números, del otro lado de la ecuación,
es decir, como queremos despejar a "X"
¿qué es lo que nos estorba?
Y aquí nos damos cuenta que lo primero que
podemos quitar es este 3, este 3 está sumando
a la "x", por lo tanto, para pasarlo del otro
lado del otro lado de la ecuación, lo que
tengo que hacer es eliminarlo o cancelarlo
de este lado de la ecuación.
Y para esto lo que voy a hacer es restar 3
de ambos lados de la ecuación, menos 3 aquí
y menos 3 también del otro lado de la ecuación,
recuerda que lo que hago de un lado de la ecuación, lo tengo que hacer también del otro lado de la ecuación.
Y bueno, -3 más 3 se van, se cancelan
porque esto me da 0,
"2x" más 0 pues es "2x" y del otro lado
me  va a quedar -15 menos 3,
así que déjame apuntarlo aquí abajo, date cuenta
que para eliminar este más 3 lo que hicimos
fue restar 3 de ambos lados de la ecuación.
Y me queda, "2x" esto es igual a -15 menos 3,
-15 menos 3 es -18, "2x" igual a -18.
Bueno, ya tengo esta ecuación
y si te das cuenta éste es justo el tipo de ecuaciones
que resolvíamos en el video pasado.
En el video pasado teníamos ecuaciones muy
parecidas a ésta y para resolver este tipo
de ecuaciones, lo que hacíamos era multiplicar
por el inverso multiplicativo, que el inverso
multiplicativo de 2 es 1/2.
Entonces multiplico 1/2 por esto y multiplico
1/2 también del lado derecho de la ecuación.
1/2 por 2, esto es lo mismo que 1,
2 por 1 = 2, entre 2 por 1 = 2, es decir, 1, 1 por
"x" es "x", lo que estoy haciendo es cancelando
este 2 con su inverso multiplicativo.
Y ya, tengo despejada a "x" del lado izquierdo
de la ecuación, mientras que del lado derecho
tengo -18 entre 2, lo cual es -9.
¡Y perfecto! ya encontré el resultado, "x" igual a -9 es el resultado de esta ecuación lineal.
Y para comprobarlo, vamos a sustituir el valor de "x" igual a -9 en nuestra ecuación original
para ver que realmente llegamos a lo correcto.
2 por -9 más 3, ojo, "x" vale -9 y 2 por
-9 es -18 más 3, y -18 más 3 es -15
y -15 pues es igual a -15, que es justo lo que queríamos. Así que ya tenemos uno de estos ejercicios
y vamos por el siguiente, el cual voy a meter
fracciones para que sea un ejercicio un poco
más peludo y un poco más difícil de resolver,
sin embargo no te espantes.
Me voy a tomar a -1/2 de "x" y a esto le voy
a sumar 3/4, esto tiene que ser igual a 5/6.
Y bueno, si más o menos tienes una idea de qué es lo que sigue, estás en muy buen momento
para pausar el video e intentar hacerlo por
ti mismo, porque a partir de ahorita voy a
buscar la solución de este problema, que
por cierto, la solución de este problema,
lo primero que voy a hacer es pasar este 3/4
del otro lado con signo negativo
o dicho de otra manera, lo que voy a hacer es restar
-3/4 de ambos lados de la ecuación.
-3/4 más esto y del otro lado, 5/6 menos 3/4.
Y bueno, -3/4 más 3/4 se cancelan, se eliminan
y me queda -1/2 de "x" y después del lado
derecho de la ecuación me queda 5/6 menos
3/4, ésta es una resta de fracciones, así
que el mínimo común múltiplo de 6 y 4 es
12 y después digo, 12 entre 6 es 2,
2 por 5 es 10 y después menos 12 entre 4 es 3,
3 por 3 es 9, entonces me queda 10 menos 9,
todo esto sobre 12 y bueno me queda -1/2 de "x" es igual a 10 menos 9, lo cual es 1,
1 sobre doce, 1/12. Perfecto, ya tengo esto de aquí, lo único que hice fue una resta de fracciones.
Ahora, lo que quiero que veas es que también tenemos que eliminar este -1/2,
date cuenta que otra vez estamos en el nivel 1.
Para eliminar este -1/2 lo que hay que hacer
es multiplicar por su inverso multiplicativo,
pero,
¿cuál es el inverso multiplicativo de -1/2?
Pues es -2 ó dicho de otra manera -2/1, pero
ojo, lo que estoy haciendo de un lado de la
ecuación, lo tengo que hacer también del
otro lado de la ecuación,
por lo tanto  también aquí tengo que poner, por -2/1, -2/1 por -1/2, estos dos se cancelan y me queda "x",
mientras que del otro lado de la ecuación
me queda -2/12, que por cierto, esto es lo
mismo que -1/6, "x" vale -1/6 y esa es la
solución de esta ecuación.
Ahora bien, sería bastante bueno que lo comprobáramos.
Y para eso déjame copiar la ecuación original y voy a sustituir a "x" por el valor de -1/6, es decir, me queda,
-1/2 que multiplica a su vez a "x", que es
-1/6, -1/2 que multiplica a -1/6 más 3/4,
vamos a ver cuánto es esto.
Menos por menos me da más,
1 por 1 me da1 y 2 por 6 me da 12, 1/12...
1/12 más 3/4, ¿cuánto es 1/12 más 3/4?
Bueno, ésta es una suma de fracciones cuyo
común denominador es 12, así que 12 entre
12 a 1 por 1 = 1, 12 entre 4 a 3 por 3 es
9, me quedan 10/12, lo cual es 5/6, que es
justo lo que queríamos llegar. Ésta era mi solución, todo lo demás lo escribí después,
esto es lo que yo tenía en un inicio en mi ecuación original, 5/6.
Y perfecto hemos acabado el nivel 2 de
ecuaciones lineales.
Y si te das cuenta, ya estás preparado para
hacer ecuaciones de este estilo,
que por cierto la única diferencia entre el nivel 1 y el
nivel 2, es que en este nivel tenemos un coeficiente
que está sumando o está restando a nuestra ecuación,
el cual hay que cancelar para que nos quede de nuevo una ecuación del nivel 1.